Would you let your children practice a
ritual written by Alistister Crowley
himself, the self-p profofessed
wickedest man alive? Because that's
exactly what this new Disney Alio movie
is teaching your children. Sigil magic,
crystal magic, summoning aliens. It's
not fiction. This is spiritual warfare.
And you will not believe what's hidden
in plain sight in this new Disney movie.
And you you have this fun character. He
goes out into a field wearing literally
this demon on his shirt laying in a
sigil and saying, "Aliens abduct me."
Isn't that the perfect setup for Satan?
He wants your children to actively
engage. Whether it's pull out a Ouija
board, pull out the tarot cards,
seances, whatever. He wants you to reach
out to him. They're known sigils that
summon specific demons for specific
things. Welcome back, Mikey. Thanks,
man. It's good to be here because this
is a perfect platform to talk about this
right here. I mean, you guys talk about
Disney. This is Satan is taking the
gloves off. He's punching the children.
Have you guys heard anything about Alio?
Uh, I think I seen the trailer to it.
Um, I obviously know it's about aliens
and stuff like this, but I I mean I can
imagine it's probably following suit
with the rest of them somehow. It's
going to be some Gnostic story. Oh,
yeah. Yeah. I think I watched an early
teaser, but after that I didn't
probably going to be surprised. Yeah, I
saw a teaser for it like a year ago, and
I heard they haven't done a real good
job at promoting this, but it seems like
they're ramping up right now. Anything
Pixar does, it's going to be big. So
great. Got a nice little alien shirt on.
That's what I wanted to ask you. Do you
see what do you guys notice about this?
Because Yeah. Alien shirt. Yeah. I mean,
when's when have you ever seen an alien
portrayed like the way that abductees
described them in a kids movie? I mean,
you always see ET or Le, you know,
Stitch from Lilo and Stitch, but I've
never seen the alien gray actually
displayed in a kids movie. So, that's a
first, which I think is interesting. Um,
what's with the one eye? That's yeah I
want catch on his left eye too. You know
the left eye is always covered. You see
so many celebrities TLC left eye and all
this stuff. There's a reason for that.
Um notice something above the the dot or
what is the dot above the earth
traveling around the sun. Yeah that's a
symbol. So it's very interesting. And
and Elio
ilio is that part of another word or
something? Is that taken out of
something else? Yeah. Well check it out.
So his name is So I've been calling him
Ilio, but they say Alio on the on the
trailer, but Alio Soloulless. So what
does that name mean? These words mean
something. Solus means something about
the what it sounds like. So look right
here. This is straight from the wiki
thing. This is the the trivia. It says
his name means son. So does his surname.
So his name means son. Okay, so the hero
is based off of the sun, which I think
is interesting. And here you'll see it
says the name Alio primarily means son
is derived from the Greek god Helios.
Oh, it makes sense why his name is Elios
or Helios, right? So he's, you know, for
one, his name means son, but not just
son, the sun god. And solus is a Spanish
word of the origin that means sun in
Latin, but it also means something else.
So Ilio means son. This comes from like
the baby names and stuff based off of
Helios. Just giving extra proof here. Uh
this today's show said what what are
some good baby names that means sun.
This was during the solar eclipse
and solace means solar. But
interestingly enough, when I did the
Latin Google uh translator, it says
Sunday. Sunday. Oh, interesting. So,
here's a Greek god, a Greek sun god
whose last name means Sunday.
I think it's very prophetic, you know.
Yeah, it really is. I mean, especially
as the whole world is like discussing
Sunday things right now, you know, this
is on the forefront of everybody's mind.
So, I mean, to have something that's
like extraterrestrial outside of this
world that's pointing you towards this
thing, it kind of makes it bigger than
it than it is here. Like, we didn't make
this up here. It's been in this universe
or whatever. You know, he's supposed to
be from Earth's, but he's not. It's like
he doesn't identify as being part of
Earth. Everything is like part of the
sun. Oh, that is interesting. Yeah. Or
maybe where the, you know, the third
rock from the sun. Everything points to
the sun, you know, like the sun's the
center of everything. But I I do think
it's interesting that he's the son god
and his last name son. He's the hero of
the movie. Um, a lot of people that
watch this channel know how to look for
gnostic themes. Is the hero have more in
common with God or more in common with
Satan? Vice versa. So why the eye patch?
I do think that is interesting. The one
eye because in Egyptian mythology, the
eye of Horus, the eye of Raw, I've
looked into this. They both represent
the sun and they're both represented by
one eye. So if it was just this, if
there's no other markers, he just had
one eye patch. I could let it slide. But
he's the sun god. His name means sun god
and he's got one eye covered. I don't
think that's a mistake. Is this Egyptian
symbol? Is it the left or the right eye?
We know this one. Yeah, you can see the
uh It's the right eye. Yeah, the eye
makeup is going outward like this right
here. Yeah. So that is the right eye
being revealed. Yeah. Interesting. So
there yeah there's no coincidences in
Hollywood right we talk about everything
is a script writer screenwriter you know
especially in animation right this is
frame by frame it's not to make this and
sculpt it and uh right um but what's
interesting is down here it calls him
the ambassador of planet earth
so
according to Bible who is like the
leader of earth the ambassador of earth
and like what scriptures are you guys
thinking of depends on what time you're
talking about. Okay, that's that's
interesting. Well, after the fall of
after the fall of man, Satan is
essentially the ambassador of earth.
Yeah, that's what I was going to say. I
was going to say it's it's Adam's that
was supposed to be the ambassador and
then he usurped after the cross. Jesus
is the ambassador of earth. Correct.
He's the second Adam. So I Yeah, I've
heard that too. But I'm just going by
these scriptures here that say John
14:30 says, "I will no longer talk much
with you, for the ruler of this world is
coming and he has nothing in me." This
is talking about Satan. Uh John 12:31-33
says, "Now is the judgment of this
world. Now the ruler of this world will
be cast out." That's talking about
Satan. Ephesians 6:12, "For we do not
wrestle against flesh and blood, but
against principalities, against the
powers, against the rulers of the
darkness of this world." In some
translations, this says age. Um 6 or
John 16:11 says that of judgment because
the ruler of this world is judged. These
are all talking about Satan. And 2
Corinthians 4:4 says, "In whom the god
of this world is blinding the minds of
humanity." So Satan is literally called
the ruler of this world, the god of this
world. He's blinding all the world. And
and he had the power to offer Jesus all
the kingdoms of the world. Mhm. You
know, we know the story where he was
Jesus was walking in the wilderness and
Satan says, "Bow to me. I'll give you
everything." But in Luke 45-6,
it says, "Then the devil taking him up
on a high mountain showed him all the
kingdoms of the world in a moment of
time. And the devil said to him, "All
this authority I give to you and their
glory, for this has been delivered to
me, and I give it to whomever I wish."
So Satan's saying, "I have the authority
to give it." And Jesus didn't say, "No
way, buddy. I own the earth." Yeah, I'm
the one that made it. Right. He knows
this is true because from the way I
understand it, dominion was given to
Adam. When Adam disobeyed God, he and
listened to Satan, he gave the keys to
Satan. Isn't that a crazy thought? I
mean, if Jesus really was the creator of
the world, like it says in John 1,
right? Um, Satan's trying to convince
him that he owns it and he's like
talking to the guy that made it. I know.
It's just wild. It is um this one, Job.
I know a lot of people um I don't know
how different people interpret this, but
I believe that Satan presented himself
to God in heaven as the representative
of Earth. Like this is like a I don't
know some kind of galactic meeting and
people are are representing other worlds
that God made. The Bible says he framed
the worlds. There's all these things
about that God made more than just
Earth. and that Satan went up there and
Jesus or God is asking where'd you come
from and he said from the earth you know
I'm representing earth so he's literally
the ambassador of earth and so you got
this hero who's the ambassador of earth
one eye covered my name means a sun god
Sunday
I mean this is nuts um Pixar made a
official post cuz in the trailer it
actually says fake it till you make it
and I was like what are they even
talking about I didn't know the context
so they're saying we've all heard the
phrase fake Take it until you make it.
And in Pixar's final trailer for their
upcoming film, Alio, you'll see that
phrase in action as Alio portrays the
leader of Earth to the beings among the
galaxy. Isn't that like a perfect phrase
for Satan? He isn't the God. He isn't
God. He wants to be God. He wants to be
like God. So, he's faking it until he
thinks he can make it. Right. Right.
Right. I think the fact that he's
claiming as he is the leader of Earth. I
think in the trailer they they they had
that little scene where he was basically
saying that right to everyone else. But
yeah, he's lying about it. Yeah. And
Yeah. I mean, he's is essentially what
the devil's doing, right? Exactly. So,
the bad guy, of course, he's going to
have Lord, of course. Lord, Lord Grigon.
Yeah. And here it says his occupation is
Lord. Well, that's his occupation. He's
the galactic ambassador. So, he's the
ruler of the whole galaxy. Wow. And
notice where it talks about his his
family. They only give information for
one person. It's his son. So, the Lord
who is the ruler of the whole galaxy has
one son. Has a son. Interesting. And
that does come up later in here.
So, I there wasn't a lot of information
out here. So, I asked Google and AI kind
of gave me an overview of information it
was finding. I was asking is Lord Gligon
trying to destroy Earth and it says that
he's threatening to destroy the home of
Alio which is Earth and Gorgon Gordon's
friends which are aliens. So he's he's
wanting to destroy multiple planets. It
sounds like the story line is that he's
potentially trying to threaten Earth
because that's where Alio is from. And
he is angry. This is Lord Gligon. He's
angry about being rejected from the
communiverse. And seeks to enact his
wrath against the ambassador whom turned
him away. Wow. The ambassadors who turn
away. So So this is the Lord the Lord
character that is angry. Like yeah, the
Bible has a lot to say about the the
Lord over all the galaxy is angry and
his wrath is coming on those who
rejected him. But listen why they
rejected him. The communiverse, however,
prioritizes tolerance and
open-mindedness. Wow. Over military
strength and um leading to Grigon's
rejection.
So, what is this teaching children? I I
see it all the time. It seems like we're
just being put constantly in these like
situational ethics situations, right?
So, is there anything wrong with
tolerance and open-mindedness?
No, we should be tolerant of people. We
should be open-minded, right? Is there
anything wrong with military strength?
No. I mean, if that's what you need, you
know, I mean, military strength. God has
military strength, right? But these two
things are being pit against each other.
Two good things pit against each other.
And we see this happening more and more
and more as we approach the end of time.
Two good things pit against each other
just for the purpose of dividing people.
And what happens is you uphold one and
not the other. Yeah. Well, you hear it
all the time how they they compare like
if you think that gay marriage is wrong,
then that's equal to racism. It's like,
whoa, there's totally difference here,
right? And this is what this is talking
about. You know, people try to say
Christians are intolerant. You're just
narrow-minded. And that's why they
reject God. Ultimately, people reject
God because they see Christians and what
we stand for. And we're in a a a world
that's accepting everything. And because
you don't think you don't accept that
stuff, you're ignorant. You're
narrow-minded. You're a bigot. And
therefore, I reject you and your God.
And so these movies are continuing to
push that narrative that God, the ruler
of the universe. And and he's coming
with anger and wrath of those who are
rejecting him, which is true. But this
is how Satan works. He gives you a lot
of truth, a little bit of error. So like
in the movie Guardians of the Galaxy,
you know, you hear the guy saying, "I
have a sacred mission. the bad guy. I
have a sacred mission to create a
perfect people. And then the next line
he's like, everyone you love will be
destroyed. Mhm. Well, that might be
true. I mean, it might really happen.
It's it's also like kind of trying to
make it seem like, well, if he's angry
and wrathful, then he can't be loving,
right? But that's not true. You can be
angry and wrathful and still be loving.
I mean, God espouses all of that. So, if
he's angry and wrathful, then does he
have a right to be? Yeah. Right. Well,
you know, that's the question. Someone
hurt your kids. Are you going to be
angry about it? You bet. Yeah, you bet.
And if you're not going to protect, it
shows how unliving you are, right? Mhm.
So, here's a little clip from the
trailer. Take note of some things. These
are um three ships, three that are
shooting lasers at all the aliens, which
we understand, anybody that's watching,
I hope, understands that this whole
alien thing is a demonic deception. And
Satan's trying to cause us to fear
whatever is coming to earth because we
know biblically Jesus is coming to
earth. So
Satan is trying to make us fear what's
coming and to actually potentially fight
against what's coming. Now Greg's going
to blow everyone up. Friends need our
help. You made a friend. You will feel
my wrath. Gordon. Hi Dad. I'm a
bargaining chip. Now say the other
thing. Oh help me father. Quiet you.
What does that unholy sound? Wow. He's
called father unholy. I know. Nobody
uses that terminology. Yeah. You know,
if he really was the evil villain of the
of the world, he wouldn't care about
holiness at all. Right. Such a good
point. So, what was going on was these
three ships are laser beaming um his
friends cuz Alio, his whole thing, this
whole movie is I don't fit in. I don't I
don't have friends on Earth. And so he's
he's trying to find where can I find
friends? And he finds these alien
friends. And so if we understand that
aliens are really demons in disguise,
he's making friends with demons. This
guy who cares about holiness apparently
wants to destroy all that. Did you
notice what happened with this this
being right here? This friend of his is
the son. Yeah. Right. Of him. Yeah. What
did he say about him?
about the father. What did he said? He
was the bargaining chip. Bargaining
chip. What do you think of? Well, in
exchange, Christ is our ransom. If it
wasn't for Christ, we couldn't get to
God. So, to to call him a bargaining
chip, the son of the galactic ruler.
Yeah. The only son. The other thing
that's crazy, too, is is you're sitting
here thinking about the they're against
him because of open-mindedness and
tolerance. And yet he has no friends.
Does that make any sense? He's in a
place where it's completely openminded
and intolerant, but then he has nobody
that he can Interesting. That's See, he
found he found his true friends are
open-minded, but they're on another
planet. I guess I guess.
So, here's another clip from the movie.
Your life isn't out there, Elio. You
need to make friends. I just want to
belong somewhere. All I ever wanted was
to find a place to fit in. So, if any
aliens are listening, please come and
get me. Okay, bye. Love you.
It's really happening.
Back home. I didn't fit in. Well, I like
you. It's like I was always meant to be
here. Wow. You know, something that
doesn't fit in. I mean, you you see the
story over and over and over again. You
saw it with with um Santa Claus and the
Misfits, right? Or the whatever the
little reindeer, Rudolph's reindeer,
like the Misfits. Yeah, there's always
this place for the for the toys or beans
that didn't play along well with others.
They did that same sort of thing in um
was it Toy Story? Yeah, one of the one
of the things Ugly Dolls. Ugly Dolls.
They did it in um they did it in uh just
blanking on the names of these things.
No, it's tons of stuff. I mean, if you
think about uh Suicide Squad,
place for the Misfits and all this kind
of stuff. Yeah. Even the new Marvel's
movie uh Marvel movie Thunderbolts,
they're a bunch of misfit like
superheroes or what do you think that
is? What's the message in that? Well,
the I mean the idea if you think of
who's a misfit in the universe, right?
God's created this perfect universe and
the only people that aren't going to
play by those rules. Sympathy for the
devil are here every time. So if you
always have these heroes that have more
in common with Satan and there's always
this Kella Deville. Oh, they they put
out these movies based on the villains
and make it a sympathetic story. Joker,
oh man, they made fun of him. No wonder
he's a suicidal maniac. Uh Carella
Deville, she was made fun Maleficent.
Yeah. They're all just misunderstood.
Yeah. Sympathy for the devil every time.
And so what 11year-old kid feels like
they fit in? He's 11. Yeah. Especially
in a world right now, social media,
non-binary, 68 genders, puberty. Yeah. I
don't know what I am or who I am. I
don't feel like I fit in anywhere. Who
What's my click? Mhm. So, what's the
answer? Oh, aliens. Yeah. Let's try to
summon the aliens because they'll accept
me, right? Who's the one that accepts
them? This demon maggot with teeth all
the way through his body says, "Well, I
I accept you. I think you're cool." And
he's tearing up. What message is you
giving a kid? You know what? I don't fit
in and maybe I'm maybe I'm not. He said,
"I feel like I should have always been
here. I don't I don't fit in in Earth. I
feel like I should have always been here
with the alien.
So, I asked, you know, is it common that
11-year-old kids feel like they don't
fit in? It's like, yes, it's very common
for children and pre-teens to feel like
they don't fit in, especially during
periods of significant social and
emotional development. Yep. So, this is
targeting an audience that already feels
this way. Yeah. Yeah. It's direct
target. And I think when you lay the
foundation at this age as well, I mean
much of the the trajectory of life is
probably formula formulated in those
early years. So if you're planting these
seeds in that early child's mind before
you even see them get to the place where
like I don't fit in, you know, it's like
they've made those decisions way back
here. So I I I think it's twice as
dangerous to to be aiming this at kids.
Yeah. So something different about this
movie. We've seen a lot of movies about
aliens and kids, you know, ET, Lilo and
Stitch, and all these things, but
something in in ALF, something that
those shows and movies had in common was
the alien comes to Earth, maybe crash
landed or whatever. The kid or the
humans, whoever they are, them. Well, at
first they're kind of scared, but then
they warm up to him. Oh, they're just
trying to get back home. Let's try to
get you back home. This movie does
something that never has been done that
I understand. And watch this clip and
you'll see. I'm trying to get abducted
by aliens.
Okay, come and get me. What in the
world? So, okay, hold on. Yeah, that's
like crop circle stuff, you know? Yeah,
but
that also kind of reminds you of a
sigil. It is a sigil. It's 100% what it
is. So, here you have a kid. I don't fit
in. And it wasn't like I stumbled upon a
crash landed alien that needs to get
back home. I'm going to actively seek
out aliens. And you you have this fun
character. He goes out into a field
wearing literally this demon on his
shirt laying in a sigil and saying,
"Aliens abduct me." Isn't that the
perfect setup for Satan? He wants your
children to actively engage. Whether
it's pull out a Ouija board, pull out
the tarot cards, seances, whatever. He
wants you to reach out to him. Did you
look this one up? That sigil? Um, so
sigils, from what I understand, can be
anything you want and they they're can
be, but there are some that are already
made. Oh, I'm sure.
So, so we we were looking at sigils from
the lesser key of Solomon. Yes. And so
those are already made. Like they're
known sigils that summoned specific
demons for specific things. That's why I
was wondering if you cross referenced it
to see if it Well, for those of that
that and you've done some research in
this area, too. Um, a lot of times these
people that actually claim they have
been abducted into the spaceship or
whatever, right? They are welcoming that
situation to happen. Yeah. They're out
there. You're either meditating or even
if you just see something fly by and
you're like, "Oh, what is that? I want
to know." You know, your curiosity is
saying, "I I welcome you. I want to know
more about you." rather than being like,
"Oh, no, that's demonic or whatever." I
remember we had a show with Demi Loato.
Remember that? And she went out in the
field with her friends and we're like,
you know, okay, what do we do now? How
do we how do we get this thing to come
near? And then they were like literally
actively meditating and asking for it to
come close. And the ship showed up and
and it was a ship that split in two,
which means it's defying physics, which
means it's not physical. This is all
spiritual. But this practice of
meditating and summoning aliens, they'll
actually use this terminology and
everything like summoning a demon. They
literally tell you summoning. I got this
from History Channel. She's going to
talk about the practice that's this
growing practice. Writer Amy Title
explains the process is part of a new
trend in UFO circles called C5.
C5 is a UFO summoning group. The people
who are involved with C5 use a special
app, certain frequencies, and meditation
to try to summon UFOs so they can see
them. Um, what Scotty was talking about,
there's actually a documentary on Little
Light Studios called Disclosed, and it's
all about this. It's 35 minutes and it
talks about what is this thing. We can
look at it from all different angles.
What the new age believe, what religion
believes, what science believes and it
always points to these things are not
physical. You can escape the abduction
experience by saying the name of Jesus.
These things appear to occultists and
newagers and witchcraft and all that
stuff. And here it is. They're telling
you if you meditate, these things will
come. That's all we got to do. Like
that's how we make contact, right? I I
wonder too like many people have used
the name of Jesus, right? Maybe they are
not living the life according to Christ
and they are just, you know, way far out
there. But there's power in the name.
And by calling upon the name, you're
inviting his presence, which God is much
more powerful than the devil. Right? So
there must be some sort of rules of
engagement with both of them. You're
calling the other one. You're giving
them the reason to show up. But when has
God ever asked you to do this? Yeah. An
altered state of consciousness. Right.
Right. To all so to enhance your
sensitivity to make contact. He's like,
"No, just just ask me." Like Yeah. Amen.
You just say it, you know, that's all I
need. I don't cry to God. I do believe
there are rules of engagement. It's like
a legal system. Satan doesn't It's the
old myth, you know, like the vampire
can't come in unless you open the door,
open the window. Satan's the same way.
He He doesn't have permission into our
lives unless we give him that
permission. But I think we do it in a
million ways that we don't believe we
don't know about. Like you bought that
little um fun statue from TJ Maxx, it's
Buddha, but oh, it's just decorative. or
um you're doing yoga or maybe you don't
realize the harm in tarot cards. I just
had some it was at a party and somebody
doing that. Any of those things whether
knowingly or unknowingly you're giving
permission to the satanic world to enter
into your life. Especially when you're
doing this stuff, I'm going to meditate
so I can see a UFO or something. But C5
right here at the near the bottom the
second to last paragraph it says um
meditation and expanded awareness
practitioners use deep meditation to
achieve an altered state of mind of
conscious or state of consciousness
believed to enhance sensitivity to
potential contact with beings who may
operate on higher dimensions. We're not
talking about other planets here, other
dimensions, the spirit world. And yet
people are still blinded by this. They
say, "Oh, they're from another planet."
This last one is interesting. It reminds
me of astral projection. I know it's
not, but it's almost like it's almost
like the invitation for that. Yeah, I
think it's very similar. Um, the same
way Satan can make you feel like you're
coming out of your body and flying over
another state or whatever, he can give
you a vision of being abducted or
whatever. I think I think fallen angels
have the same power to give you visions.
Um, so C5, you know, there's the app
that you can actually download to do
this stuff. So this is not some corner
of the web stuff. This is pretty
trending stuff. Reviews serious
technology advanced research. Over
100,000 acronym for star. Yeah. What is
Sirius is the brightest star in the the
uh the solar system. It's the ninth
canon of the it's it's basically what
they get the dog star. I mean that's a
very
Yeah, that's too Yeah. What were you
saying about the Well, the group that
put it out, Serious Technology Advanced
Research, the acronym for that would be
STAR. Oh, you took all that.
Interesting. Wow, good catch. Break.
Hey, subscribe to
If you want to learn Spanish, a great
way will be watching our videos for
practice.
In this scene, he goes up to this like
AI entity that's in the shape of an
oraoris, which is a snake consuming its
own tail. Right. And it looks like a
like a snake. Yeah. And this this being
this thing that he's going to is made up
of cards. We're going to find out. And
it says, "I have the answers to the
universe. Think biblically, a snake that
has wisdom and you come to me and I'll
give you all the answers." Right? Um
here we see I am the universal users
manual. I contain the secrets of the
universe. The cards hold the secrets.
The cards hold the secrets. It's made up
of cards. The Orborus made up of cards.
Secrets of the universe. And here we see
that you know what the orus is this
occult symbol. It has to do with death
and rebirth. It's like the rise the
phoenix rising out of the ashes. It's
all this occult stuff.
And you see these cards have sigils on
them. Yeah. Like some serious tarot
tarot looking stuff. So sigils all
through this movie about what? getting
answers, summoning aliens is all the the
stuff that they're saying they do.
And you know who this is? Oh, yeah.
Grant Morrison. Grant Morrison. This is
a clip from 2000 2001, something like
that. He was at this thing called
Disinfo Convention, and he's telling you
how magic works. He's a self-professed
magician and he said, uh, I always
wondered how people got abducted by
aliens. And he said, "I went to Catman
do to get abducted by aliens and it
happened to me and anybody anybody can
do it. If you just make sigils, you can
be abducted." Wow. Is there any
practicing magicians in the audience?
Put your hand up if we got any. Yeah.
Come on. Bold. A few. Okay. By the time
we finish this, you're all going to be
practicing magicians. Like everyone
here, we're trying to figure what's
going on. Why do we feel different? Why
don't we fit into this world? Why do we
think that they're not telling us the
truth? So I went out and I read Robert
Anton Wilson's books when I was 20 years
old. He says we can talk to aliens. We
can talk to people from Syria. Is he
talking crap? He said Alistister
Crowley's got methods for contacting
alien intelligence and for changing the
world. Is he talking crap? So I did it
and no he's not talking crap and we can
all do it. When I started doing the
invisibles which is a comic book for
people who don't haven't seen the thing.
It's a comic book which is kind of my
attempt to explain what happened to me
after I've been abducted by aliens in
Catmoo in 1994. And the only reason I
was abducted by aliens in Catmand do in
1994 is because I went to Catmand do in
1994 to be abducted by aliens. And it
works. I found out that if you do these
things that you're told by Alistister
Crowley, by Wilson, by all these people
we read and all these people we've been
consuming, but we don't do it. If you
actually do what they say, things happen
and we can all do it. So these things
happen. Magic works. And when I started
doing the comic, I found that you could
actually make magic happen by writing
things and changing the operating system
of the universe. This magic works. So
I'll tell you something you can do while
I'm here. One of the best techniques and
one of the easiest techniques to prove
that this thing works is to practice
sigil magic. First thing you do, write
down a desire. Make it something easy
that is likely to happen, something
possible. People like Austin Osman
Spear, the magicians from the early part
of the century or Crowley or the chaos
magicians from the 80s who were big
inspiration on me.
They used this stuff. And what you can
do is this. Like I say, try this at
home. Write down a desire. Take out the
vowels and you'll be left with a string
of consonants. Take out the repeated
consonants. You'll be left with a string
of consonants that have no repeats in
it. You know, whatever. X Y A D
whatever.
Turn that thing into a little image.
Take the D, draw a big D. Then you've
got a T. Draw a T under it and keep
reducing it down until it looks magical.
And there are no rules for this thing.
Do it until it looks magical. At that
point, you now have a sigil. The sigil
will work. You can project desire into
reality and change reality. It works.
[Applause]
This is verifiable. People have been
telling us about this for thousands of
years. You know, the Tibetans have been
telling us about this. The Mesopotamians
have been telling us about this. And why
is it being made occult? Because
Coca-Cola got the secret. These people
know what we're talking about here
because what you do is you create a
sigil.
Wow. So that that speech he's given, I
think it's it's kind of based on a book.
M and uh there was a book where they
compiled from all these people who
practice magic and it was like a
deinformation or yeah a debunking or a
disinformation guide to like real magic
or something like that where they took
all these people like Crowley Morrison
etc and said tell us what magic really
is and his chapter in the book it's
called pop magic. Oh Grant Morrison was
in the book. It was in the book. His
chapter was on sigils. Wow. I just came
across this this past week and because
we were looking at another video that
had a book, but yeah, it was all on
sigils and he was saying like this same
exact stuff. Wow. In in this in this
chapter and and he said sigils always
work. He repeated it more than once in
the chapter. He's saying take notes.
Don't just you know you you're basically
saying like you guys are dumb if you're
just listening to this and go home and
don't practice it. Do it because it
works. I know it's scary to see a room
full of people like this and there's
like a bunch of people that actually
believe this. Dude, that was the year
2000. This stuff is only getting more
and more acceptable. We used a clip of
that in in when we did the documentary
on replacement gods and so I haven't
even actually seen that. That was nuts.
Yeah. If you track everything he said
with what we're talking about in this
movie, he talked about Alistister
Crowley summoning demons through sigils.
And we have a kid laying on sigils,
summoning demons. Well, aliens, what he
what he said, he said, "You you make a
sigil, you can summon aliens." And he
was saying, "Where'd it come from?"
Alistister Crowley. And then you see the
allseeing eye literally in the clip, the
same symbol. Do you know why he says it
comes from Crowley?
Crowley was the one who edited the book
um the lesser key of Solomon. Oh,
interesting. He didn't compile all the
information, but he edited it. Wow. And
in that book are 72 sigils that summon
72 different demons. One of them
Osmodius. Yeah. Crazy. This is what you
see in the Joker. Mhm. So, yeah. They
say when you invoke that one, he can't
get rid of him and basically he'll make
you mad. That's what happened to Jared
Leto. Heath Ledger. Heath Ledger. That's
what it was. Heath Ledger. But even Jack
Nicholson was like, I told him not to
take that role, you know. Well, so like
you were talking about, I did try to
compare these symbols with existing
sigils that are out there. Um, but you
can see it's like he said, you they're
free form. You can make them from
whatever of anything. And what do we see
here? He's laying on the sigil trying to
be abducted by aliens. And that's what
he said. He said exactly the key for
summoning demons. Demons can't come
unless you invite them. So what do you
do? You go out to a field. You lay on a
sigil and say, "Aliens abduct me.
They're going to come." How many
children are going to react reenact this
because they don't fit in? Yeah. You
know, usually when you're a kid and you
lay on the ground like that, you usually
see it in snow like a snow angel. Yeah.
So, it's kind of interesting that it's
like he was laying on the ground like
that. And so, this is a a page about
sigils. And you notice how in the center
it has alpha at omega. I did not notice
that the W, it looks like a W, but it's
an omega in Greek. Alpha in the middle.
It also has tetragamaton in the top
left. What's
in Hebrew it's Yhwh. Well, that's the
transliteration in English. On the next
side it says Adonai. Yeah, Michael. And
then says Michael
Elope.
Yeah. I don't know what this one says. I
can't see it upside down. And then
there's another
one Agla and Elope. But at least two of
the names in there. It has Michael
Cinnabon. And um yeah, some of the names
of some of the names of God in there. in
the middle, the circle with that plus is
the symbol of the sun. Um, Tamuz, cross
of Tamuz and all that. All these, all
these stars are inverted. All I was just
about ready to say that they're all
upside down in the same position with
Maltese crosses. Yep. Maltes crosses
everywhere. And so this is the page of
sigil magic. And you see it comes from
Lester Key of Solomon like you were
talking about. And this is very satanic
stuff that's in this movie. And it says,
"A sigil is a type of symbol used in
magic. The term usually refers to a
pictorial signature of a spirit such as
an angel, demon, or deity. In modern
usage, especially in the context of
chaos magic, a sigil refers to a
symbolic representation of the
practitioner's desired outcome. So the
symbol itself represents a demon and you
get what the practitioner's desired
outcome is which is what
derived from the Latin sigelum meaning
seal in medieval magic. The term sigil
was commonly used to refer to occult
signs which represented various angels
and demons which the practitioner might
summon.
You're using the symbol of a demon to
summon a demon. Yeah. So when this kid's
laying on a Yeah. This is right in your
face. Yeah. It's like for whatever rules
that they have to play by, they're
they're saying without shadow of a
doubt, this person is inviting me in
there is basically what you're doing.
And most parents have no idea. I mean,
who's going to sit down and do this
level of research research, you know,
you know, like this particular
character. It's like, oh yeah, yeah,
they're my kids will like this story.
It's about outer space and a Disney
film. Yeah. And it's about
don't bully people. Well, don't you
know, he needs friends, you know, and
all this stuff. It's always wrapped up
in a package like that. Acceptance. And
Disney's taking off the gloves, man.
They're coming after your children
full-blown. When when Frozen 2, when
Ella was saying Earth, wind, fire,
water, it's all about the earth spirit.
The water spirit. I mean, that's getting
so that's already right in your face.
But now we're talking about sigil magic
and summoning demons, not oh, I stumbled
upon an alien. And that shows up in
other cartoons, not just Frozen. Oh,
yeah. It was in Elemental. Yeah. Right.
It was also in Moana. Yeah. Captain
Planet. You see the same thing in
Voltron. You see the same thing in um
Power Rangers. Like all of that stuff.
You can go on their information pages
and you can see how they're talking
about how their characters are
represented by Earth, air, fire, water.
It's all there. There's a Disney series,
a cartoon called Witch, Wii T. It was
acronym and it was all about these
witches. And at the beginning, they're
like earth, wind, fire, water, all that
stuff. Yeah. The thing is, when you
think about it, Christian parents, how
many of how many Christian parents would
take their kids to a demon summoning
place, or would like be in a place where
it's that's being happening? Yeah. Where
where that's happening, right? But you
know, you put it on a screen where they
are doing it with the kid and the kid.
It's about how you package it, right?
Because most people are going to be
ignorant about sigils and things like
that. They don't know what that is.
You're just taking part. Yeah. You're
taking part in in a, you know, a demon
summoning
place. Yeah. If there was a flyer at the
mall that said, "Bring your children to
the new age convention where we will be
summoning demons." You would say,
"There's no way." And you tear that
thing down.
But now it's like, oh, wait a minute.
See, Satan is so on one million moms,
right? Yeah. And isn't that crazy that
like they they they they couldn't get
you to come to their meetings like that
behind closed doors, but but but you can
have the meeting in your house with the
TV. That's an invitation. Is nuts. So,
this was the original uh No, it's not
really. This was an AI generated thing.
Isn't it? It's the same. No, but isn't
it in the uh the trailer? Doesn't he lay
down in like a pentagram? Oh, no.
I actually had Chad GBT make this. I
didn't I didn't I've never seen that.
So, there is no difference in these
pictures. Yeah. I mean, literally, this
is a different sigil. That's all it is.
But if if it looked like this, parents
would be more in tune with that symbol.
This is actually a hexog. But they would
be like, "No way. You're not going to
watch some show like that." Oh, this
one. Okay. Yeah. Yeah, let's let's go.
Let's bring the whole family. Um, what
do you notice in this picture?
Well, gems around
like crystals and Yeah. Yeah. And that
that tends to be part of like the
elemental magic, you know, they talk
about calling circle. Here he is in a
circle. Yes. You know, and he's
summoning what he wants to happen. So,
here he's on a rooftop surrounding
himself in a circle of crystals and
inside his treehouse again with crystals
and he's got the alien on a whiteboard.
I mean, this is like um
uh this is vision board stuff like
divination. You write what you want. You
put a picture on the board. You you
focus on that thing. Law of attraction
type stuff. So he's got literally what
he's divining on the board while he's
surrounded by crystals and he's using
technology to try and reach out to them
to communicate which Keith's done
amazing research on. A lot of this
technology started with a cultists who
are trying to talk to the spirit world
through TV and phones and all these
things. And so yeah, this is I'm not
reaching this is like really a practice
that goes on. There's people videos of
this stuff happening. She's got the
crystals in her hands because they
believe that crystals have the power to
hear from the spirit world. If you ever
when you're a kid, you ever put together
a crystal radio. So, there's a kit you
can get from Radio Shack, which nobody
knows what Radio Shack is anymore, but
there's no power in it. Like, there's no
battery, but there's a little crystal
and you hook these wires to and a
speaker and you can actually pick up
radio stations just from the crystal.
And so, that's why they believe that
crystals have power to pick up things
that are out there in the air. you know,
the prince and the power of the air. And
isn't that interesting that really the
Bible describes, you know, God and Jesus
as the rock, right? Yeah. You know, and
it's like here they're using rocks
essentially to Well, God's kingdom is
full of precious stones and and stuff,
but Satan is always counterfeiting,
corrupting everything that God made. And
so, here's Alistister Crowley. Notice
his hat has the allseeing eye on it.
Yep. But he was communicating with a
demon called lamb, a a Tibetan name. The
lamb in Tibet means way, which is a
direct counterfeit of Christ. But he saw
this being. He saw what people today say
are aliens, associate as aliens. But and
that's what Grant Morrison was saying
that Alistister Crowley knew how to talk
to aliens. He used sigil magic. But it's
a straightup demon. I mean, this was the
wickedest man alive. and and notice all
the occult I mean all the ancient
Egyptian symbology.
Um so anytime you see this stuff the one
eye all that it goes back to this. And
so I was I was saying that Disney people
are saying Disney did a bad job of
promoting this but if you go to a Disney
park right now you see him with his best
friend the alien and it says welcome to
Alio's guide. When I ever hear guide, I
just think spirit guide, guided
meditation, all that stuff to an
intergalactic adventure. And so to enter
in, you have to walk through the portal.
I mean, this is the portal that he was
beamed up into the ship. Interesting. So
the doors open. You're literally I I
think all this is kind of like an
interactive Bible guide for Satan. You
know, it's like when when you do a Bible
study, the last thing you want somebody
to do is do you accept? Will you begin
to follow Christ? will you accept this
doctrine or whatever? And when you write
yes or you actively say yes and you get
baptized, these are actions saying I
accept this, I do this. And so when you
have video games like uh I can't
remember the name of that video game,
but it was like you you have to choose
will you reject Yahweh? Remember that
game? It was in the anime documentary.
Yeah. Yeah. It was um I'm not going to
remember it. But all these are like
you're Satan is getting you to a place
where you're actively choosing. Yes, I
reject Yahweh. You walk through the
portal which is literally being beamed
up to the aliens like teni aami or
something. Yeah. Shimagami teni. And it
says here you can let the aliens just
substitute the word alien for demons.
You know what it is. Here you can let
the demons know you're ready for the
ultimate space adventure. Oh, and don't
forget to smile. Yeah. I mean, this is
just such propaganda. And then they put
it on the wall and parents are like,
"Oh, go over there. Let's take a
picture." Now your kid is on the sigil.
It's no longer just alio. You're and the
parents are actively helping their kids
act out what's in the movie. Go lay on
the sig. I want to take a picture and
remember this. Yeah. Wow. Oh, go into
the beam like you're being abducted by
aliens.
I mean, if the watching the movie wasn't
bad enough, now you have an interactive
experience where your kids can actually
do it. Well, that's kind of a new thing,
too. People have always been like weary
of being abducted. Yeah. Not like openly
like, "Yeah, let's let's make it
happen." You know, I want to be
abducted. Like, it's a big positive
thing. But now all the new ages and
everything is saying these they're here
to help us because our world is in
chaos. That's that's not a mystery. Like
everybody can tell. Even the secular
people know our world is like crazy. And
so I do believe, you know, the
military's on the news saying they're
real. We talked to them. They're here.
Whatever. I believe when first contact
comes, these demonic beings are going to
say, "We're here to help. No, we're
going to get rid of pandemics. We're
going to stop wars. Peace and safety.
When they say peace and safety, sudden
destruction will come upon them. And
it's going to deceive millions. And if
you don't embrace these all knowing
beings that are way more smarter than
us, then you're going to be looked at as
public enemy number one. Well, you know,
if if a lot of people see this as
reality or you know how how movies can
be put out, right? Jaws gets put out and
now everybody hates sharks and every
piece of water that they swim in, they
they're going to see sharks, right? So,
this is just planting in people's minds
that okay, you can communicate with
these things and they're here for our
betterment and and you know, whatever.
And so, as this develops, I guarantee
you in the end of time, Satan is going
to be coming out into communication with
him and whatever wants to destroy the
earth is evil. Exactly. And hey, we have
the secrets to peace. This happened on
our planet back at our home place and
you know they did this and this and this
so don't do what they did to lose their
planet. Yeah. And people on Earth don't
accept you. We will. You know they're
they're not openminded for you. Yeah.
Yeah. They're not open-minded and they
don't have tolerance. Adventures are way
more amazing with a partner. That's
that's me and my bestest space bud
Gordon. So he's like, "Man, this is my
friend. Look at this." Dude, if you came
across something like this in real life,
it would be horrifying, right? But
Disney and Pixar, they know how to make
this thing look fat and cute and chubby
and can't can't really eat you because
it can't move quickly. Yeah. He's like,
he's your best friend. So, why don't you
take a picture with me and my demon
friend here?
There are so many cool demons hanging
out at the Cuniverse. Zoom on over and
say hi. Who are you saying hi to? This
the bad guy. aliens, but it's like,
well, I guess not. He's he's the
villain. These people are the friends.
But it's like
they're taking you every step of the
way. Lay on a sigil, get abducted, go
hang out with the cool aliens.
Interesting how like he looks like he's
either wearing armor or looks very
robotic,
but they're all smooth and colorful and
bright and big, you know, bigger,
happier eyes, smiles on their faces.
Yeah, they really know how to make one
attractive versus the other. So true,
man.
And so I'm sure you guys remember Roger
Morno and in this clip, but in this he
talks about that demon spirits will
manifest as visitors from far distant
galaxies and that they're actually going
to be pushing for a Sunday sacredness
thing. Listen, the priest said
that as the times on this planet gets
more and more difficult
and calamities of all kinds are striking
the planet more and more frequently.
Demon spirits are going to
impress people with with the the
importance of Sunday sacredness.
And he said it's going to be done in a
unique manner because he says spirits,
demon spirits will
declare themselves to be inhabitants of
far distant planets in the galaxies
that are coming to warn the inhabitants
of planet Earth of the impending
destruction of the planet unless
something seriously
proper is done to avoid it. I really
think we're in a time where our world's
in chaos, riots, pandemics, climate
change, volcanoes, earthquakes. I mean,
and he says that he was told by a
satanic priest that Satan's going to
appear as visitors from far distant
galaxies to say, "We have come to help.
If you don't do some major changes,
you're not going to survive." And part
of it is the importance of Sunday
sacredness. Mhm. And here's your hero
whose name means sun god Sunday. Mhm.
Alio Helios, the one eye who is a son
god. I don't think it's I don't think
it's a coincidence. I think all this is
propaganda pushing towards a one world
religion, pushing towards sympathy with
the devil, embracing
demon spirits who are, you know, Satan's
never come out with red horns and a
pitchfork. serpent in the garden, a dead
loved one, aliens who are here to help.
I think that's where we're coming to.
This definitely planting a seed in the
younger generation's mind. And um you
know, even if it takes till those
generations grow up, which I don't think
it's going to. I think we're here. But
yeah, this is definitely one to be
careful with. Yeah. So I I say boycott
this movie. Don't let your kids see it.
And and do some research. Yeah,
definitely. And the thing is is Satan's
out here making these colorful cartoons
to tell your kids that demons are your
friends. Where are the Christians at?
Like I don't I don't hear sermons
teaching the truth about what aliens
are. I don't I don't see any like
Christian cartoons like Superbook or
anything saying, "Oh, we shouldn't trust
these beings." Yeah. So, there's a lot
more evidence trying to show that
they're friendly or whatever. Yeah. So,
we actually put together this book
called Aby's Strange Dreams about a girl
who's having encounters with an alien
and with an angel that says you can talk
to the dead and a and a dragon. And when
things in her life start going wrong,
her mom says, "You need to pray and put
on the full armor of God." And that's
when she sees their true colors. And she
prays and puts on the full armor of God.
And she says, "And leave in the name of
Jesus Christ." And they have to leave.
And I want children to know when you're
faced with something like this because
this is this is a common occurrence. Now
I I get emails from people that said so
there was there was a situation where a
woman said her and her daughter watched
the UFO documentary on Little Light. In
that documentary they saw where some of
these beings these alien beings appear
as blondhaired, blue-eyed human looking
things. And her brother is an atheist
and his wife. They have a three-year-old
son and they called her because they
were like, "We don't know what to do
about this. Will you come talk to our
son?" She went and the little
three-year-old son said that every night
three beings are walking through the
wall, grabbing him by the ankles and
trying to pull him through the wall. Oh,
wow. And described them as these blonde
hair, blue-eyed beings. And she said
right then she was I remember that
documentary on Little Light Studios. So
she told him, "These things are demons
and stuff." and she prayed with him and
he's never had the experience since
because she knew what to do now her
brother and his wife are like, "Okay,
maybe there's something to this whole
Bible thing." Like, they're open to
Bible studies now. And I just think it's
so important. I mean, when Satan's
spending millions of dollars putting out
this message, the church needs to speak
up. And so, my personal experience was
the church didn't talk about it, and I
gravitated towards the occult because
they were. So, this book is a free
resource, absolutely free. If you go to
cantruth.org and click on merchandise,
there's a a a place to order the book.
You can order in bulk and give it out to
all the kids, you know, all the kids in
your family, your church, whatever. And
especially during a time like this when
this movie is coming out. Nice. You had
a bunch of kids that um you gave this to
at a school. How'd it go over? Oh, man.
I I've had more. So, uh, there was a
fundraiser that made 2,000 copies of
this, and that's why it's free resource.
They're gone from January till now.
They're gone. And people from other
countries have even asked, but it costs
too much to ship. Um, but yeah, there's
been whole Pathfinders groups, um,
church groups that are are getting this
book because they see all this stuff
that's coming out right now that and
that there's nobody talking about it.
So, as far as I know, it's the first
spiritual warfare book for kids, and I
just got the the next shipment in of
2,000 copies. So, get them while
supplies last. And if you guys feel led
to help keep this thing a free a free
resource, that would be awesome, too.
And you can do that on the site. But I
just think as Christians, we need to
talk about the truth, or else kids are
going to be seeing this and say, "Man,
aliens are our friends, and I know how
to contact them. Crystals and sigils.
Let's do it." Yeah. Well, Mikey, thanks
for coming back on our channel and uh we
miss you and it's been awesome here. I
miss you guys, man. It's so cool to be
back. Yeah, thanks for sharing this with
us and just keep doing what you're
doing, man. He's out there. Check out
canon.org. You'll get more of this kind
of stuff and you can get the free book
if you uh we'll put a link in the
description below. If you like this
video, like, subscribe, and hit the
notification bell so you know when we
launch new videos and drop a comment
below and we'll try to get back to you
if we can. What?
Say that again. No. No. I don't know
what to say.
[Music]